THE NEW COMEDY "GHOSTED" BRINGS THE
LOLs WITH "BEVERLY HILLS COP" THRILLS
AND "GHOSTBUSTER" CHILLS.
Okay, well, she's talking again,
so that's, uh, that's progress.
IT'S ONE OF THIS FALL'S MOST
ANTICIPATED COMEDIES.
I could have died in there!
Aw, someone need a hug?
CRAIG ROBINSON AND ADAM SCOTT ARE THE PARANORMAL TEAM OF YOUR DREAMS.
It's a little dynamic I like to call partnership.
Get your hand off me.
Yep.
"GHOSTED" PREMIERES
SUNDAY OCTOBER 1ST ON FOX.
Your dad and I spent 15 years together on the LAPD,
and he always told me his dream
was for you to go to college.
SAT prep course? Dude, I'm 12.
Turn to page six you lil bitch, and if I
hear that you haven't been studying,
I'm gonna come see you myself, you understand?
You married?
Sort of.
Oh, are you going through a divorce?
No, she was abducted by aliens.
Sweetie?
Okay, I know what you're thinking.
It's crazy, actually I was-
Who the hell are you?
Why did you take us?
I'm Barry.
I'm your kidnapper and unfortunately,
that's all I can say about that.
That's not very fair is it?
I work for The Bureau Underground.
We investigate the paranormal and
anything outside the scientific realm.
Is this a hidden-camera show?
Where's Alex Trebek?
Wait, did Alex Trebek have a hidden-camera show?
How did I miss that?
I am Captain Lafrey.
I am not exaggerating when I say that the
fate of the entire planet may rest in you.
Oh, hang on.
Hey, sweetie. What's up?
I'm sorry. Did she just say the fate of the entire planet?
She's talking to her daughter.
Yeah, she took the call. She's the rude one.
Starting now you two are working for The Underground.
It all leads to Water Bridge nuclear power plant.
We need to get you inside that reactor room.
Hi, yeah, the printer is jammed.
I'm gonna send over two of my best guys.
How's it going, Ma'am?
This is one of those. This is a copy machine.
Uh-huh.
I'm more of a fax machine guy,
Max-the-fax machine guy.
That has a fax machine in it.
This one?
Yep, that one right there.
2-in-1.
Since this is an all-in-one wraparound,
I think that's more your specialty.
Maybe you should just go ahead-
That's enough backtalk, bro!
I'm gonna go.
No! I want you to see this!
Why? She doesn't-
You will show me the respect I've earned!
Yeah, I can't be here for this.
And scene. That was great.
Watch your face.
You can stay in here cuz you're certifiably
nuts and you might get me killed.
Woah! Leroy!
I could've died in there!
Aw, someone need a hug?
Want to go to an independent
coffee house and talk it out?
Something's going on over there. Lift me up.
I wanna peep through the vent.
Or just like maybe redo that the other way around?
Why?
They have guns and bullets and we are frightened!
I repeat! We are very very frightened!
I can't believe you let me come with you.
You begged me, remember?
"Leroy, please, I need this!
Everybody hates me! I'm a loser!"
Why was the head yelling?
The head should not have been yelling.
It's a good question.
Gentlemen, welcome to The Bureau Underground.
Congrats, man.
Wow.
Congrats to you, partner.
Okay, you just called me partner.